hello guys i'm brian right i'm under a 6
does andreas six toasts here from east
los i slash sister to my girlfriend
Veronica six those who's also sisters
with Alesia six dose that's right people
there are three of them three and there
are different Cassandra there's four of
them good for your dad I'm sure that
doesn't paranoia him at all and it rains
also on uh East lows hi people so you
know earlier in the intro the other
danger I said that I didn't they're
always correcting me every six days
anyway I'm introducing Iraq Iraq ax I
gave her a warning that they are violent
sometimes but they're supposed to be
funny the context of them is more funny
yeah see if you find it funny there's a
game we're gonna play it's called don't
look away from the screen
oh you're gonna have to pay attention to
the video I don't care how grossed out
you get if it happens to get that way
five nights of Sesame Street here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the profession that's one of the reasons
probably
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I love their commitment to the
batshit craziness you gotta admire that
hear it if it doesn't make sense you're
like at least they committed to what
they were going out to do oh my gosh I'm
so disturbed you're disturbed I'm so
trust me there's way worse videos out
there from these guys way worse I think
I've seen a video with the Ronald
McDonald guy before
yeah he's the creepiest [ __ ]
like that's one of the creepiest
characters I've ever seen yeah where
he's like hanging with a couple of kids
or he's a dick hanging with a kid for
the day I think so yeah oh my gosh that
was insane to watch what I like about
these guys they normally do skits that
take place in like this scene that's
happening normally a normal day is going
on and then something crazy happens this
is the first time that I recall where
they did a trailer and doing a mock
trailer it can be a little bit more
challenging than doing a full sketch
actually yeah because you got to get
multiple locations you got to get
different scenes going all the time sure
they're shorter shots but I imagine that
it's a much bigger shot list than it is
to just do a regular type of you know
short film or sketch so kudos to those
guys for doing all that like they got
the Sesame Street outfits they got the
five nights at Freddy's outfits they got
two months Cookie Monster yeah yeah as
cool their production values really gone
up like their violence makeup people I
don't know who they are but they've
always done a good job and the concept
itself is funny Sesame Street but it's
like a horror story like five points
don't show my nephews and use that they
all probably love that ah a fee no will
love that yeah you know how old is she
she's two two-year-olds love these kind
of videos I grew up on them and I turned
out fine
this is a beautiful story that they just
showed us beautiful story you really
think you're not mine I turned out great
I turned out great yeah yeah you're a
little you're a little batshit crazy I'm
into gerbils
I sure have told you that I shan't have
told you that
oh okay turtles are cute I guess the way
I'm talking let's just okay that's
oh stop I mean I'm dating your sister
and that'd be a weird image where you
have no idea what that means I don't
want to know good no no this is so
horrid comedy I was watching uh what
kind of reminds you of like the style of
have you seen this is the end yes
it kind of reminds you of that style
where it's a comedy but it's like a
horror film at the same time and I get
that same supernatural horror vibe from
this dealing with demons and stuff you
can get that
Hey
I'm actually in the middle of shooting
on Ryan's shotgun an axe axe body spray
which descent died here it can kill you
if you inhaled too much of it yeah um
she has filled my front lawn well I
don't have a front lawn it was my mom's
front lawn she'll never approve of me
Andrea no she well she busy you well I
thought your answer was yes she will one
day she will approve just keep it up I
hope so she does she ever verbally told
you that no but I can tell ya she hung
out with you guys when you guys were
together and she seems like she likes
you that's good the whole joke with the
black guy that eyes first I feel like
that jokes been done to death but what
they did here I thought was very funny
yeah well I came actually going after
the creepy little girls and I feel like
any black guy can kick my ass oh yeah
like why does the black person always
die in the movies yeah in real life
they're like the toughest [ __ ]
I don't it doesn't make any sense
because every black I know is tough
skinny or buff they're tough
yeah hey that rhymes with skinny or buff
they're tough and they're a little rough
Oh yours no special
but I do like what they did with Ronald
McDonald like including him as that
special priest they bring into the
haunted house right and because Ronald
McDonald has been so creepy in these
that it kind of seems like it would be I
would I wouldn't mind if raka raka did a
full on like maybe a half hour short
film and then maybe a feature film
I feel like they'd be really good at
that because so far other sketches are
very just randomly sporadic and fast
paced and violent I felt like if they
learn to slow down a bit it could be
like some really cool videos that are
like literally solid short films I'm
sure they can I wonder how long it took
them to shoot this thing I'd imagine it
took quite some time I mean they haven't
come out with a video in like over a
month is that your mom again
oh it's Ryan my boyfriend Ryan I love
this guy hey doing drea good beautiful
I'll call him back
okay okay the last part where the woman
who was turning into a bird and then she
started that was told I didn't expect
that to happen at all now was she raping
Big Bird that's messed up
rapes not funny that's not funny at all
that's really that's my point with these
guys is they go so out with things that
are so grotesque that you shouldn't be
laughing at it but the concept is so
ridiculous that it's kind of funny like
when you're first watching this woman
raping Pigford you're like that's
disturbing but when you're talking about
it and you like say the sentence out
loud you realize how ridiculous it is
right and she's a female
and her pants are still long and still
on and we are looking at a still image
right now the exact moment or she's
doing well he didn't [ __ ] deserve
oh yeah because here he knocked up the
girl yeah that was some good effects
when that thing came out that's
disturbing
oh yeah she got bit by the little thing
and infected her you have you have
solved the mystery injury that's why she
turned into a bird all right guys thanks
for tuning in to the channel listen if
you're new to it there's this button
here you can subscribe today and then
you can call yourself a reject because
it's cool when youtubers name that are
fans something does that mean I'm a
reject a few subscribe to the react just
Andrea yes you can catch on East Lowe's
high seas that you could watch seasons
one through three you starred in two and
three right yeah and you can follow her
on social networks such as the Instagram
because she uses that a lot what's your
Instagram me Mia DRTs
I x52 Dre 652 yes there's a description
right here and it's in the description
box too so she post a lot of photos she
does post a lot of photos and my scenery
guys want to let get some nice scenery
sometimes I do selfies but you know if
you want thanks for describing how
Instagram works on you and what you can
post I don't I do nipple shots no jobs
primarily nipple shots just selfies of
the nipples yeah well like like that
close I've seen your nipple that like
that close
actually my nipple yeah your nipple your
girlfriend when we went to two Kern
River
she took a video of your nipple and it
was on my phone and it looks like you I
was passing by was like what are you
doing
you better like race I after you're done
with that and she never did and I had it
and I had to race it myself is
[Music]
[Laughter]